básicamente unos temas muy importantes
en lo que respecta a la educación es la
revalorización de los sueldos de los
profesores recordemos que son de los
peor pagados de los países de la ocde
por lo tanto emanuel macrón recordó que
el comenzó ya una reforma en este
sentido que fue gatillada por la crisis
del cob y de 19 y propuso otras cosas
por ejemplo que se incorpore el deporte
en las clases que se incorpore también
el arte y la cultura dijo que iba a
hacer también una reforma del liceo
profesional que se pague mejor a los
alumnos en práctica en fin y ahí fue
cuando arremetió marine lepén porque
ella dijo estoy muy preocupada por
nuestra juventud están deprimidos por la
crisis del coi 19 también se sienten muy
solos por eso yo he hecho un punto
fuerte de mi programa a la juventud les
voy a pagar cuando trabajen y estudios
les voy a dar una ayuda voy a pagar en
los transportes por ejemplo ya que
muchos jóvenes que estudian en zonas
rurales por ejemplo tienen muchos
problemas de movilidad les voy a dar un
dinero prima para que sea gratis para
ello el transporte les vamos a pagar las
prácticas y entonces esa fue un momento
en que marie le pen aprovechó de
arremeter con una parte muy importante a
lo que respecta a la juventud de su
programa entonces ahí ella le dijo usted
le va a arreglar el sueldo pero aquellos
profesores que los alumnos den buenos
resultados le dijo esto fue una idea que
le dio mckenzie en referencia no cierto
a las consultoras internacionales
concretamente la estadounidense que ha
hecho mucha polémica pues fue muy
empleada en el gobierno de manuel macro
y no pagó sus impuestos en francia él
dijo estaba esperando que me sacara esto
yo pensaba que se había olvidado eso con
respecto básicamente a lo que fue la
educación